foreign
uh but no I know I thought that's a
common issue actually I would argue if
this has just been my subjective
experience
um dating more intelligent men and being
with myself
um
both ends we've both been lonely people
hard you don't meet other people that
are as smart as you and it is just like
imagine trying to speak a different
language you wouldn't be able to
socialize with others around you but
again
if there's a social trade-off whereas
like you might have a guy like maybe
he's not you know with IQ points IQ is
everything but he's more socially Savvy
instead of like two nerds in a house
that I like don't maybe don't have as
many friends
nature of the Exotic
ism
we get a lot of clients
maybe they are working in Tech
those kind of people
those people I think
for some reason they I call a
generalized book could often find a coin
physically social
the EQ side of things
[Music]
you know I
think creatives
um so it depends on the way that the
intelligence manifest s
[Music]
one is literacy one is
is
[Music]
how you can be technically good on some
things it's true the new Society is all
about computing
right so
a male as a male is always a about to do
something because
in a way even I'm coming from a country
which is Italy I mean I grew up in art
everywhere so it's really good things
and
instead the way there's
something like that if you're there
with a new new business people like
is
Facebook they're not interested to go
through it and make something else
you just fix it
so everybody will be sick so
beautiful
basically
we're always sit here
you won't have in any
interview between 10 years ago even to
have the willful game
you know people do it is something they
like it
thousand for the guy
rather would you rather spend the rest
of your life with someone you don't like
that much
or be lonely
I I take
the
companionship
[Music]
okay okay
uh
[Music]
I'm sorry like I think I also think
that's a problem for other women like
our grandmothers
that's not me but um you know I think I
would compensate like every other woman
that's out there over the age of 35 in
the world I would just give me a group
of girlfriends
is
[Music]
[Music]
doing work writing having great
experiences rather than big shots
would you do
it man yes
suicide
well that's even very lonely
you know like
three quarters of suicide
they don't have a social life
because nobody has a safety you really
talk to
you I've been quite an active in all my
life around
[Music]
I've been a little bit known for a
central thing
because if I used to be organized party
you know I used to be amazed
and then obviously College started
everybody started
most of the people just come
yeah
I had a lot of friends
[Music]
everybody
you know and they have to say that it's
not really no
no it's mostly about the time I see
people I know why you talk with the guys
that you don't say the way it is it's
still a person
on your business
all right but that's me it's difficult
for guys
because uh we need to look as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible